[Music]
fusion power has a certain reputation
something in the realm of a holy grail
but not in a good way
there is a famous joke about nuclear
fusion about how it never becomes a
reality you can google it if you like
but really the moment we are in with
nuclear fusion today is probably more
exciting than it's ever been
there's more activity in the fusion
world than ever and not just in
government research labs there's also an
emerging private fusion industry that's
attracted billions of dollars in capital
in recent years
government and private investors alike
realize that we've got to find a
solution that's going to allow us to get
to net zero targets
this is one of the hardest but most
rewarding problems that humanity could
work on ultimately we all want the same
thing we want someone to put electricity
on the grid from a fusion power station
as quickly as possible
frankly the scale of the challenge three
thousand gigawatts of fossil fuel to
replace
there's not many things that can do that
in fact there may only be fusion that
can really do that
and while many in the scientific
community predict fusion power will take
decades some in the private fusion space
believe we'll get there in just a few
years as soon as the 2030s
there's a lot of money going into these
companies and it's very interesting and
exciting there are some
i really love and some i would rather
love about
the world is desperately searching for a
replacement for fossil fuels now
scientists and startups are betting that
a commercial fusion reactor is finally
in sight
[Music]
we're looking at visible light coming
from the plasma
the plasma is this sort of hundred
thousand degrees temperature but what
you actually see is the coldest part
the hottest part you really don't see it
because it's too hot
to emit light in the
in the visible isn't it
yes
when i started i was doing numerical
modeling and then i realized that
running the machine was a lot more
interesting and a lot more fun for me
my work is stressful my work can be very
demanding in terms of time
but this is still
one of the most exciting places in the
world
here in oxford you'll find arguably the
most successful fusion experiment on
earth
jet the joint european taurus taurus
being the technical term for doughnut
which is how the reactor's shaped
jet's been operating since the early 80s
and only by 1997 we'll be really ready
to try proper fusion and we produce 16
megawatts of fusion power at the time
which is like a few wind turbines it's
pretty significant and it shows that
fusion is possible
the 1997 experiment set records but the
reactor was only able to run for less
than a second
the team spent the next two decades
cooking up a new approach and in 2021
they gave it another shot
we always knew that we could do better
the last two days before christmas were
dedicated to these experiments just
these window parameters where we could
get more
and we did
three
two
one
jet more than doubled its previous
record producing more energy than any
fusion experiment in history
we couldn't hug we couldn't we couldn't
high five nothing because we have to be
at two meters from each other
but you know it was obvious that this
was a record it was successful you could
see that it was successful
it's a real step towards the ultimate
promise of fusion
a cheap emissions-free power source with
virtually unlimited fuel
but maybe don't break out the champagne
just yet
so in the 1997 experiments we produced a
lot of power but very transiently so it
ramped up and then we lost control
now we ramp up and sustain for five
seconds
[Music]
so what exactly makes fusion such a
tough problem that sustaining it for
five seconds constitutes a world record
nuclear fusion
once it's perfected fusion power will
give us an unlimited supply of energy
so nuclear fusion is really what is
happening inside the sun where
lots and lots of hydrogen atoms are
moving at immense speeds
and every so often some of them fuse
together to form helium
now the process at the atomic level
leads to a very small amount of loss in
mass
and that little amount of mass actually
generates a lot of energy
and you do that millions and millions of
times and you get the sun
look we know fusion works it's happening
right now in our sun but the reason it's
happening in the sun is because of the
mass of the sun so massive has this huge
gravitational force which is pushing
those isotopes of hydrogen close enough
to fuse
we obviously cannot recreate the mass of
the sun here on earth so instead we have
to give that fuel even more energy
so we take a gas
we put a huge amount of energy into it
and that turns it into the fourth state
of matter of plasma if you consider
water for example it's ice
then you warm it up and then you get a
fluid and then you want further up you
get the steam and if you then increase
temperature even further then you get
plasma
common plasmas include lightning
neon lights
and these things
we need temperatures 10 times larger
than in the solar interior so this is
about 100 200 200 million degrees and
only at those sort of temperatures do
you get fusion to happen here on earth
heating something to 10 times the
temperature of the sun is to use the
technical term very hard scientists have
been working at it since the 1930s the
major breakthrough has been the first
tokamak experiments in the 1960s in the
former soviet union they
achieved several million degrees and
this was a real brexit
tacomax is still one of the most popular
ways to create fusion that's what jet is
along with many other government-run
reactors around the world
using powerful magnets to contain the
plasma they've achieved temperatures of
100 million degrees and well beyond
but there's still one big milestone we
need to reach before fusion power
becomes a reality
net gain
we need more power out than put in to
heat the fuel in the first place
if we can't generate more power from
fusion than we put in then the whole
thing's a bust
unfortunately no one's ever done it not
even the brilliant mines at jet
that's all kind of part of the plan
though because jet isn't actually
designed to solve fusion all by itself
it's just set up for a much bigger
project called eater
no no eater
we are building this
experimental
machine in the south of france ether
which is going to be big and it's the
first one that will produce really more
energy than what it consumes
eta is a massive international
collaboration between 35 different
countries and everyone involved seems
pretty confident it's going to get to
net gain for the first time
so fusion's just around the corner right
well
with the eater project the first plasma
is supposed to be
created by 2025 but full fusion reaction
isn't expected until 2035.
so if ether were the only bet that we
were making on fusion then it would be a
safe bet to say that nuclear fusion is
going to take decades
and that's too long for the climate
fight
even the most optimistic scientists
think that fusion power may not be
developed for 50 years if then
if ever
some think we can get there much faster
there's more than 30 private fusion
companies around the world
and it feels like every month or two
there's another private company that
springs up somewhere with another great
idea about how to do this the amount of
funding going into fusion has also been
scaling there's more private funding
going in to fusion per year than there
is federal government funding in the
united states
the private fusion space is still small
in terms of
budget and people when compared to the
mainstream but if you look at the rate
of progress i would say it's it's much
much faster and
i
do think that it will be the private
side that produces the first viable
technology
canadian fusion company general fusion
is steering away from the traditional
tokamak design
if you have followed fusion at all in
recent years you might have come across
this steampunk octopus an earlier
prototype of their reactor
it's very analogous to
a
fusion version of a diesel engine so you
basically you have this very large
cavity that's opened up inside of liquid
metal
and into that liquid metal we inject a
high temperature plasma of hydrogen
we can now perform this compression to
heat up that plasma very much the same
way you think about a piston compressing
and heating the fuel in a diesel engine
this is a steam driven compression
process using an array of drivers
it compresses and heats this magnetized
plasma
to fusion conditions
general fusion's reactor would create
brief bursts of fusion energy an
approach they hope will achieve net gain
more easily than a tokamak
founded in 2002 and supported by
investors like jeff bezos they're one of
the furthest along in the field of
fusion startups with plans to build a
demonstrator plant by 2026 in oxford on
the same scientific campus as jet
this thing won't actually put megawatts
on the grid but it will prove that our
approach to fusion in a power plant
relevant environment can actually make
fusion happen
aiming to break ground in a matter of
months the company is running full tilt
to work out all the kinks before
showtime
this is about two-thirds of the full
scale that we'll need in our fusion
demonstration plant
so it's it's mostly at this point a
question of understanding the properties
of the the plasma and the plasma physics
to be confident that that will scale as
we build the larger version
the alarms you hear when we start
charging are alerting you to the fact
that we're starting to charge this
machine
you hear a ping from when the plasma is
uh interacting with the wall of the
machine
you can see at the time you heard that
that
thump that's when the machine created
the plasma
[Music]
it's really exciting to see what's
happening in the private fusion industry
of course i came to general fusion
because i like general fusion's
technology that's one man's opinion
i think we have
my view is the first really good shot on
goal
but what really feels good is there's
going to be lots of shots on goal right
and i'm very confident we're going to
score the win that we need
[Music]
not far from general fusion's
headquarters you can find another fusion
company
helion energy one of the most
buzzed-about fusion companies in the
world is hunkered down in some former
boeing hangars just outside seattle
what we have tried to do at helion is
approach fusion from a different
direction than a lot of other people
we looked at the state of the art of
what was being built in fusion and
thought really there has to be a better
way to get to commercial fusion faster
that might sound like hype but there
really is something radically different
about helion's reactor
almost every idea behind a nuclear
fusion startup or a company is to rely
on the heat that is generated by fusion
and then converting that heat into steam
which is then used to turn turbines to
generate electricity
now helion says that it doesn't have to
go through that heating and turning a
turbine phase
so we do something called direct energy
conversion where we take the magnetic
energy of the fusion system the charged
particle energy of the fuel and directly
extract that to electricity
we inject our fuel we magnetically
compress that fusion fuel fusion begins
it pushes back on that magnetic field
so the good analogy is regenerative
braking in your car we then directly
regeneratively take the electricity back
out of that fusion expansion and turn
that into electricity
by cutting out the steam step for fusion
we can radically increase the overall
engineering efficiency of the system
we aim for a system now that can be much
smaller required a lot less of the
complexity and the challenges and really
from my point of view a lot less of the
time
that pitch was good enough to get
silicon valley giant sam altman and
peter thiel on board as investors
the company's 500 million dollar series
e-round makes them one of the best
funded fusion companies in the world
they're also making one of the most
ambitious predictions in the industry
the goal is to get this up built by 2024
running generating net electricity from
fusion for the first time
timeline is the driver it's always the
driver and so if it's a question of well
it could be a little bit better but take
an extra year we say no we're going to
make it a little bit worse but get it
done a year earlier
it's a silicon valley mentality of how
can you build as absolutely as fast as
possible
[Music]
you happy with the gas pressure
everything's isolated
gas pressure
[Applause]
nice good shot
that was easy
back in oxford
first light fusion is taking what might
be the most original approach of any
fusion company borrowing from a branch
of fusion called inertial confinement
the idea behind inertial confinement is
you hold plasma for a very short time
in a very small space
so one example of inertial confinement
is where lasers very high powered lasers
are used to heat a very small amount of
hydrogen for nanoseconds that is
billionths of a second
this has been done before most famously
at the national ignition facility in
california
but first light has come up with a new
approach we call it projectile fusion we
have a high velocity projectile it flies
in and it hits into our what we call a
target
and the target has to focus the energy
of the projectile into the fusion fuel
this is one of our targets
and this is the this is the key
technology to our approach to fusion
so this is uh completely turned into a
plasma by the the force of the impact
and the energy released
in a power plant one of these targets
would release enough energy to power the
average uk home for
over two years
that sound
that's the projectile being fired out of
this gas gun at around 15 000 miles an
hour
to generate power you have to do that at
a repetition rate you have to do
a certain number and it's the energy you
release every time times by the
frequency and that's the power so in our
power plant design we'd be doing this
about once every 30 seconds
so we recently showed fusion in
our lab with the projectile driven
approach for the first time just simply
experimentally it's a big proof of
concept that it can really work if we
look at the actual amount of fusion we
produced then that number by itself it
was 50 neutrons so we're not hiding it
right it's not very impressive
but the point is that's exactly what the
simulations predicted and that's what
gives us the the
very rapid we hope pathway forwards to
to
improve that number i hope we're not
talking about 50 neutrons at the end of
the year
so there's these disruptive technologies
which are coming into our space which is
great we want new ideas we want people
to come and tackle the big challenges
that we face there's lots of startup
companies some of them will fail some of
them will go to the wall some of them
will wildly succeed that's just healthy
some on the scientific research side of
fusion are more critical of the startup
phenomenon
few private fusion companies have shown
any results beyond fusing a few atoms
and many scientists worry that these
startups are promising too much the cons
in my mind are the promises by companies
who either have a concept that we have
already for good reason put a part and
and knew why they won't work or
completely new concepts
some change them
every other year
and then they still promise fusion
energy by 2030 or something and i don't
like that too much because i'm afraid
that if there are so many promises not
kept
that this would not be positive for
fusion energy in general
if you look at the time scales that
governments work at
in research
that's completely different than the
time scales that entrepreneurial private
industry works at it's not that there's
a problem there with government but you
know they're a different set of metrics
there they're largely research driven
organizations
you need to look no further than
commercial access to space
spacex they've created what people
thought would never be possible which is
reusable rockets
nasa was never able to achieve that
because they weren't motivated by the
same things and so when it comes to the
last mile of commercialization that's
where you really need to hand the baton
from government to private industry
from what i know some of the private
sector is very serious and is bringing
significant
capital and significant engineer
advances it needs to promise things
on the time on a realistic time scale so
knox next year but
and and the time scale of about 20 years
is realistic
it remains to be seen whether the
silicon valley vc type approach will
actually get us to commercial fusion
faster
one thing is for sure though
progress however slow and incremental is
being made
and if we're going to get to a
fusion-powered future we're probably
going to need both the painstaking
research and the risky new ideas
i think the rate of progress is really
driven by the imperative and to be
honest i mean let's just be honest as a
society over the last 20 or 30 years
we've been pretty comfortable with
burning fossil fuels the fact that we
have to stop it
now drives imperative this is the most
important question for mankind because i
mean you need electricity or energy for
everything
we have a lot of developing countries
and if these countries want to come to
our standards of living there's no way
other than provide them with cheap
energy
and better co2 neutral otherwise we have
a climate crisis
[Music]
each fusion technology has a slightly
different flavor in terms of its
ultimate value proposition
and so i think that you're going to see
a portfolio of technologies being
commercialized over the coming decades
that address different parts of the
market and the market is huge and
diverse
the
total addressable market for fusion is
on the order of a trillion dollars a
year
it might be decades before fusion
becomes a reality but it's the kind of
cheap unlimited power that you would
want to give
a civilization to be able to do all the
things it wants to
imagine if you could make a lot of
rocket fuel to create an entire fleet of
rockets that would go and mine asteroids
because you know at some point we're
going to run out of metals
or you could remove existing carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere back down and
bury it deep underground
that process requires a ton of energy
but if you were able to create nuclear
fusion you could imagine restoring the
earth's atmosphere to pre-industrial
levels
and these are the kinds of applications
that really cheap and clean energy can
enable humanity to do
i want my kids to have a future that has
the possibilities that i've had
so i hope we get fusion
and i think private public it all needs
to come together because this is worth
it
you